apartheid un término contundente y
significativo que ninguna otra ong
internacional de derechos humanos ha
utilizado en el pasado para describir la
política de israel hacia los árabes en
su suelo y los palestinos en los
territorios ocupados
la realidad actual es que
independientemente de la solución en la
que se crea ya sea un estado dos estados
o una confederación es hora de que el
mundo se dé cuenta de la realidad sobre
el terreno y active todos los resortes
de los derechos humanos para acabar con
esta situación el régimen de aparte es
hoy una realidad para millones de
palestinos
según la ong 700.000 colonos viven
actualmente en la cisjordania ocupada en
noviembre se ha cruzado un límite con la
expansión de estos asentamientos en
jerusalén este que dejaron aislados a
varios palestinos en el preámbulo de su
informe human rights watch recuerda que
la parte se caracteriza por tres
elementos principales la intención de
mantener la dominación de un grupo
racial sobre otro un contexto de
opresión sistemático del grupo marginado
y actos inhumanos
el ministerio de asuntos
y condenó las acusaciones de absurdas y
falsas una postura similar adoptó el
foro ql un grupo de reflexión
conservador este informe es propaganda y
nada más está lleno de errores prácticos
e inexactitudes no es la realidad
ya veréis incluso antes de la
publicación de este informe la corte
penal internacional anunció el mes
pasado que habría una investigación
sobre los presuntos crímenes cometidos
por israel desde 2014 en los territorios
ocupados el primer ministro israelí
benjamín netanyahu calificó la decisión
de antisemita